et si notre monde n'était pas le seul ou
l'existence est absurde
reportez-vous au menu des dangers pour
découvrir comment ne pas périr
vous devrez nous aider à démanteler le
volant vous obtiendrez plus d'espace
anatomie un liquide
ou 5 heures
et tout ça la chope qui m'ouvre
1 2 3
je vais vous laisser converser me tenir
à l'écart en prétendants ne pas écouter
ironie reste l'ironie je suis dubitatif
c'est l'aventure pour laquelle nous
vivons les mini détritilles les mauvais
moments ne sont pas plus éternels que
les moments agréables c'est une pièce du
grand puzzle de la vie
c'est très répugnant et cependant
parfait
[Musique]